hamas fires hundreds of rockets into
israel while the squad rushes to defend
them
president biden inherits middle east
peace and instead foments middle east
war
and the 1970s gas lines are back baby
i'm pensive this is the bench bureau
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn don't let bigtech track
what you do anonymize your web browsing
at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment quick a reminder let me just tell
you
inflation it's coming it is happening
the reality is that when you pump insane
amounts of money into the american
economy without any necessity to do so
you drive up prices and you drive down
the value of the american dollar that's
exactly what's happening right now well
what has historically been the best
hedge against inflation
you guessed it precious metals which is
why you should be looking to my friends
over
at birch gold if your investments are
tied to dollars you're sitting on a
ticking time bomb at this point do what
i do
invest a portion of your savings into
gold and silver birch gold group those
are the people i purchased from
they're who you can trust to convert an
ira or eligible 401k into an ira backed
by gold and silver that is correct
through a little known tax loophole you
can convert your retirement savings that
are tied to the stock market
into an ira backed by precious metals it
is your hedge against inflation and
uncertainty
in the markets tax bends 47 47 47 for
your free information kit on precious
metals iras or to speak with a birch
gold representative today with ten
thousand customers an a plus rating with
the better business bureau
countless five star reviews birch gold
can help you as well text ben
247 47 47 invest in gold before it is
too late again text ben 247
47 47 to get started alrighty well we
begin today
with this insane barrage of rockets
being shot into israel by the terrorist
group hamas which is in control of the
gaza strip ever since israel withdrew
from the gaza strip in 2006
because every israeli concession
historically has been met with more
palestinian
aggression well now you have 400
rockets that have struck southern israel
since yesterday
all of this predicated on the lie that
israel was stopping worship on the
temple mount
a lie also predicated on the notion that
israel was seizing territory
in sheikh zarah which is sovereign
israeli territory number one and number
two
was the subject of a 50-year lawsuit
over four houses that's what this whole
thing is supposedly about
that's not what any of this is really
about i'll explain in just one moment
first
the jerusalem post reports a man was
killed in ashkelon on tuesday morning
zakah reported zach has the emergency
services in israel as barrages of
rockets on tuesday afternoon
after the iaf struck a number of
terrorist targets and killed multiple
gaza terrorists so far over eight
buildings in ashrod and ashkelon
have been hit by rockets according to
israel police one of the buildings hit
was a school
because hamas doesn't care where they
are firing when when you see the media
treat this as a quote-unquote cycle of
violence understand that israel
uses or attempts to use as much accuracy
as possible in targeting terrorists
in the gaza strip or in judea and
samaria they do so
despite the fact that these terrorists
deliberately hide themselves among
civilians
for years everybody has known that
hamas's base is underneath a hospital
this is nothing new
hamas always shields itself with
civilians hoping that if israel
is to get at them they'll have to kill
civilians in the process and then be
blamed by the international community
for doing so
by contrast israel does not do that with
its own military and
hamas islamic jihad palestinian
authority they just fire rockets and
and send terrorists into civilian
centers they do not give a damn about
killing civilians
so they've been shooting these rockets
almost randomly into israel
into israeli cities ranging from
jerusalem i had a friend in jerusalem
last night was telling me what it's what
it felt like to hear the the
sirens go off and then a rocket hit hit
fairly close to populated areas in
jerusalem
ashkelon is a city that is located not
all that far from the gaza strip
but israel is a tiny country so
basically most of southern israel a lot
of central israel
has been put under warning of rocket
attack tel aviv
attack people have been told that they
should
have access to a bomb shelter hundreds
of thousands of israelis have been
relegated to living underground for the
moment
this happens every couple of years
thanks to the gentle mercies
of hamas and the palestinian authority
and islamic jihad supposedly the peace
partners in this
garbage non-existent peace deal so far
over eight buildings in australia and
oshkosh been hit by rockets according to
israeli police
one of the buildings was a school an
eight-year-old woman was seriously
injured in the rocket strikes a number
of other people were lightly injured
the idf the israeli defense forces have
approved the call-up of 5000 reservists
on tuesday the iaf prepared for a large
scale offensive in the gaza strip as
rocket attacks against southern israel
continued again israel has total air
superiority
in the gaza strip the reason they send
in troops on the ground is specifically
so they don't kill civilians
theoretically they could bomb from the
air the way that bill clinton did in
yugoslavia
but they don't do that and they don't do
that because they want to avoid civilian
casualties the idf chief of staff
lieutenant general aviv kojavi
also ordered the reinforcement of the
gaza division with infantry and armored
brigades along with the continued
redeployment of intelligence in air
units
kojavi ordered the continued striking of
hamas and palestinian islamic jihad
weapons and storage sites as well as
expanding
of the strikes to other targets
including operatives of the terror group
the idf struck over 130 targets
throughout gaza overnight on monday as
southern israel was bombarded by over
400 rockets since monday afternoon
including
injuring close to 50 israelis on tuesday
at about noon
palestinians said that the idea struck
an apartment in an eight-story building
in gaza's rimal neighborhood killing two
senior palestinian islamic jihad
commanders
and fatally wounding the brother of baja
abu alata who was killed in a targeted
idf operation
in 2019 by the way notice how
the palestinian terrorists are hiding in
apartment buildings again as stated
shortly afterward a number of barrages
of rockets were fired toward astrod and
oshkolon with three residential
buildings hit directly by rockets
leading to light injuries hamas took
responsibility stating the all-kassam
brigades directed the largest missile
strike so far
on the occupied cities of ashton
oshkolon in response to the enemy's
continued targeting of houses and
resistance men
and the next is greater god willing
notice
ashkelon these are not cities that were
historically
arab cities okay these are cities
particularly ashkelon that
these are cities that are along the
coast of israel okay and these are
cities
that were under israeli control before
1967.
okay so the the the notion that this is
all about the 1967 borders
is just a lie okay so the the the
rocket barrages continue to this hour
israel is retaliating by attempting to
specifically target terrorists
now why did all of this happen when tel
aviv has opened its bomb shelters of
course
why exactly is all this happening right
now now there are people who will lie
and they will tell you that this is all
about a legal dispute over those four
houses in sheikh jorah also known as
shimon
sadiq was
jewish territory okay in in the 1870s
there were jews who literally bought
that land like for money
they bought that land they built a
jewish city in 1948 when israel
was put under assault by a series of
arab nations
during the israeli war of independence
sheikh zarah or shimon has
that was then called it was captured by
the arabs jordan captured it
okay all the jews were forced to flee
because all these arab countries are
essentially euden ryan there are no er
there are no jews who live in jordan
there are no jews who live in hamas's
stand there are no jews who live
in the palestinian authority 18 of
israel's population is arab
a major arab party right now could
decide who the next prime minister is so
when people talk about apartheid states
understand that there's one side of this
conflict in which literally zero jews
live
and there's another side of this
conflict in which twenty percent of the
population is arab
and you're absent on the supreme court
and arabs have high positions in that
society
in any case sheikh jorah was captured by
the jordanians
okay that in 1967 israel won jerusalem
back
and then there was a legal case filed by
people who had owned legal title to
these houses
in sheikh jarrah okay these lawsuits
lasted for basically 50 years
and the people who were living in these
houses understood they didn't have legal
title to the houses they'd been
squatting since jordan took over the
houses
and then when israel won the houses back
they said okay well you have to return
those houses now
and the folks just didn't move out and
they didn't pay rent and so finally
after 50 years of these houses being
passed down in terms of legal title
and and squatters kids and their kids
kids living in these houses
the the courts found that you have to
pay rent or you're going to be evicted
just like everywhere else on earth where
if you don't pay rent you're evicted
so there are these small scale evictions
that were going to take place it's about
300 people who are going to be evicted
doesn't mean they were evicted from
israel doesn't mean they were even
evicted from shigera
it means they were evicted from houses
in which they were supposed to pay rent
because the developers wanted to knock
over these houses and build an apartment
building
okay this is what supposedly led to this
conflagration if you believe that
i have a bridge in brooklyn to tell you
this has nothing to do
with a legal dispute between private
parties under israeli law
and that is not what this is about this
is about the palestinian authority
attempting to avoid responsibility for
canceling another election
this is about the biden administration
making overtures to terrorists in the
middle east
this is about hamas attempting to
out-compete the palestinian authority in
terms of how much we can show we hate
the jews
and this is about a western media that
is always willing to go along with just
a little bit of jew hatred so long as we
are talking about israel
i'll get to that in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact
that if you want to feel safe and secure
in your own home one of the ways to do
that make sure that your home is covered
by ring
devices when we move to florida first
thing my wife said get the ring devices
on the home not just because we want to
know
about people who are visiting the house
but also because i have three young kids
and i want to make sure i can keep an
eye on them
sometimes my little one gets away from
me and i'm like i don't know where she
went she can move now
and i check the ring devices i know
exactly where she is
makes me feel a lot safer makes her a
lot safer go check out ring right now
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone
ring has hassle free easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams so you'll never
miss a visitor you can keep those
packages and delivery safe
with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell if someone stops by or
something is going on
ring will let you know which is super
awesome there's a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ringgit.com forward
slash men
it comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
the chime pro
don't wait get a special offer on that
ring welcome kit at ring.com
it comes with that ring video doorbell 3
and the time pro it's the perfect way to
start your ring experience go to
ring.com
that is ring.com go check them out right
now okay so first excuse that is being
used for this violence
is the sheikh zarah issue second excuse
that's being used is israel put up some
gates
a few weeks ago with regard to ramadan
to prevent people from congregating
on the steps and causing chaos so people
decided okay we're going to fuss and
we're going to riot so israel removed
those gates
and the rioting continued because this
is not about that okay i've been up to
the temple mount the temple mount is a
completely
islamic walk dominated area okay jews
have basically very little ability to be
up there
arabs have complete ability to be up
there al-aqsa mosque is open
all the time there is a palestinian
school that has been built in the corner
of the temple mount remember this is the
holy site in judaism right it's the
third holy site in islam supposedly it
is the holiest site in judaism
bar none no question i mean i literally
have a giant picture in my home
of the temple mount in my home because i
am a religious jew and this is the
holiest sight in judaism right this is
where the temple once stood
so i know the area very well okay the
the temple mount
is used for soccer games by palestinian
children the temple mount
is used for communal activity on a
regular basis
okay and israel allows all of this
because israel put the place under the
control of the islamic walk
having been up there if you are a jew
and you start to mumble prayers they
will remove you
out of deaf friends to the islamic walk
if you go seriously
it is you want to know about actual
apartheid jews are not allowed to pray
on the temple mount muslims can do
whatever they want on the temple mount
they can fly kites up there they can
play soccer they do
they do all this by the way they can
destroy antiquities up there which
they've also done
but if jews go up there and you mumble a
prayer the islamic walk will charge you
and start shouting you this actually
happened to us
and then you will be removed by the
mishtara by israeli security
while people shout at you allahu akbar
again been there personally when it
happened
so the notion that the temple mount is
somehow being cracked down upon that the
israelis don't want the palestinians to
prep there is just a lie it is not true
at all okay what was actually happening
is that the israelis knew
that the temple mount was going to be
used as a staging point for attacks on
israelis because it turns out
one thing that typically you don't get
in many communities including muslim
communities is the use of your holy
sites
as staging areas for you know terrorist
attacks but that's not true
with regard to al-aqsa in this
particular case we know and the israelis
knew that these were going to be used as
staging points
to create a conflagration the reason for
the conflagration
is really twofold one is that the biden
administration made very clear upon
entering office that they were going to
re-tilt
the playing field toward the
palestinians so the trump administration
decided in the aftermath of obama's
radically anti-israel
administration an administration so
anti-israel that on the way out they
allowed a u.n resolution to pass that
suggested that the temple mount was not
even jewish territory
and had no historic connection to the
jews i mean it's unreal how anti-israel
and borderline anti-semitic the obama
administration was
in the aftermath of that trump came into
office and trump
then said well no israel is our ally and
we are not going to make concessions to
palestinian terrorists and we're going
to cut off funding to palestinian
terrorists
which is to say hamas and the
palestinian authority and islamic jihad
all terrorist groups and you know what
happened
violence went down violence went down
under trump for all the talk about how
trump was going to cause conflagrations
nothing like this happened under trump
trump moved the american embassy to
jerusalem
and there was talk that the entire
middle east was going to go up in flames
it didn't happen
there was talk that peace would never be
made instead the abraham accords sprung
up
between israel and the uae and bahrain
and and
yemen and a bunch of other countries
okay and all of these countries started
making
morocco they started making peace deals
with israel specifically because
they had an outside relationship with
israel that had nothing to do with the
constant militancy
of hamas islamic jihad and the pa so the
trump administration approached this was
basically
we're not going to pretend that we have
to play even-handed broker between
terrorist groups
and a historic american ally we're just
going to say we're on the side of the
american ally
and if these terrorist groups wish to
act with any level of responsibility
if they wish to make peace they
absolutely can they didn't so nothing
happened
and there was no violence there's very
little violence during the trump
administration
the minute joe biden comes in he
immediately starts negotiating with the
iranian government which we'll get to in
a second
not only does he do that he restores
american aid hundreds of
millions of taxpayer dollars to
palestinian terrorist groups
flashback to april 8th remember it is
only the beginning of may
flashback to april 8th this is the
jewish virtual library reporting
fulfilling a campaign promise to restore
aids to the palestinians cut off by
president trump
president biden announced plans to
provide the palestinians with 290
million dollars in assistance the state
department insisted the allocation was
consistent with u.s law
though some members of congress said it
violated the taylor force act which
prohibits u.s assistance to the
palestinian authority until it ends pay
to slay policy
of providing stipends to terrorists this
is what the palestinian authority does
by the way they literally pay the
families of terrorists
and you get to fund that now thanks to
joe biden at the end of march 2021
the administration announced it was
providing 15 million dollars in covet
assistance and another 75 million
dollars in assistance for infrastructure
health and civil society groups
here's the thing about the palestinian
authority and hamastan
money is fungible if you give them money
for one thing they don't use it for
that thing they then use it for all the
other things at the beginning of april
the administration informed lawmakers
who would give the palestinians
40 million for law enforcement and
security which means arming fatah fatah
is the armed military wing
of the pa it's also a terrorist group
and another 10 million for peace
building initiatives
through the u.s agency for international
development they also said they would
restore funding
to the unrwa which is basically just a
a group under the un auspices that funds
palestinian terrorist groups that's all
they do
and palestinian education toward
terrorism
the department said it was contributing
150 million dollars to the unrwa
and said the united states needs to be
at the table to ensure that the reforms
advance efficiencies and
are in accord with our interests and
values
okay now the reality is of course
israel's position is that the unrwa
perpetuates the conflict and does not
contra
contribute to its resolution so joe
biden comes in he immediately restores
aid to the palestinians
now normally this would mean the peace
breaks out right according to the theory
yeah that's not what happened
instead here's what happened mahmoud
abbas who is in the 17th year
of a four-year term they last held
elections in the palestinian authority
in 2004. they haven't held any elections
since then because abbas is afraid that
hamas is going to win
hamas of course is an even bigger
terrorist group than pa and fatah
all of whom are terrorist groups okay so
there are no
there are no good guys when it comes to
pa fatah islamic jihad hamas
none of these people are people you'd
want running a country
they are all terror funders and or
actual terrorist groups
okay so mahmoud abbas had an election
scheduled for this year
he cancelled it okay he cancelled it
like a week before the violence broke
out
this is all a giant distraction because
here is the rule
when it comes to the arab world and when
it comes particularly right now
not to the arab world but to the
palestinians when it comes to the
palestinians
every failure of governance is blamed on
the israelis and if you are in serious
dire political
trouble you immediately launch a series
of escalatory violent actions against
israel that's what you do
yasser arafat used to do this all the
time when he was in trouble when there
were corruption allegations when he was
on the brink
of maybe having to sign a peace deal
yasser arf would immediately launch
violence
he's done this over and over and over
again this is why i say every time
israel
makes concessions which would create
some sort of pressure on the
palestinians to come to the table
precisely the opposite happens when
israel unilaterally pulled out of the
gaza strip
the first thing hamas did was russian
burn all of the areas that israel had
handed over these beautiful greenhouses
all of the homes they just burned them
to the ground and then they started
they started firing rockets at israel
okay so the biden administration has
fomented that by
handing money to exactly these people
which is just a wonderful wonderful idea
and then hamas was going to win this
election so mahmoud abbas canceled the
election we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about a
simple fact and that is if you've got a
medical issue you really should just go
get it dealt with
and the way to get those issues dealt
with especially if they require a little
bit of discretion
do it online with roman you get a free
online evaluation and ongoing care for
erectile dysfunction
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home a us licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships you free with
two-day shipping
the whole process is straightforward and
discreet getting started is simple just
go to getroman.com
ben complete an online visit take care
of your id without leaving your home
complete an online visit today to
connect with a healthcare professional
and get it taken care of go to
getroman.com
ben right now you'll get 15 bucks off
your very first month it's really time
to take care of your ed and remember get
started today you'll save 15 bucks on
your first order
of ed treatment go to getroman.com
ben right now again get 15 bucks off
your first month of ed treatment
this is a problem that has a solution
there's no reason for you to wait around
and hope that it just goes away instead
go get it solved right now get roman.com
ben get 15 bucks
off your very first month okay so the
palestinians canceled their elections
in late april this is the washington
post reporting april 29th
palestinian authority president mahmoud
abbas said thursday he will indefinitely
postpone the first palestinian elections
in almost a generation
these are the people we're giving aid to
by the way i made a dispute with israel
over voting in east jerusalem
and sagging poll numbers for a boss's
own ruling faction and that's really
what happened here
the fast approaching election with
separate votes for parliament and
president starting next month would have
given palestinians their first chance to
elect their leaders since 2006.
that year's election shocked the region
when the militant group hamas was
elected to govern the gaza strip
leading to a blockade by israel and an
enduring schism in american
in palestinian politics abbas 85 has
been in power for 16 years
16 years speaking before a meeting of
palestinian leaders in the west bank and
gaza abbas laid the blame
squarely on israel yeah there it is
suggesting that
israel was blocking palestinian
residents from being able to vote
israeli officials said nope no
that is not right jerusalem's deputy
mayor floor hassan ahum
said i think this is a handy excuse from
what my palestinian friends tell me
but that's the whole region right the
handy excuse is always israel
so they need palestinian authority
needed a distraction from the fact that
we could go and cancel the elections
so they decided okay we're gonna ramp up
the violence they started
putting out propaganda about how it was
time to attack jews
they started posting videos of
palestinians beating up jews for example
there was this tic tac they're calling
it the tiktok intifada in which
palestinian teenagers were going around
in jerusalem finding jews and beating
the living hell out of them
you can see some of these videos here's
posting a video of palestinians beating
up jews
the uprising over sovereignty over the
capital has turned into a fire spreading
from ali to ali
and from refugee camp to refugee camp
okay you can see israeli soldiers being
beaten up call sounded and they were
stronger than the whistling of the
occupation's bullets
okay this is all from palestinian tv
right this is fatah pushing this stuff
with the glorious music right you're not
going to see this on israeli tv
right on israeli tv you don't have
anybody who's encouraging violence on
palestine this is palestinian official
tv
this is the fatah ruling authority
television station
meanwhile in the gaza strip a senior
hamas member is preaching
on their television station about how
it's time to buy some knives and chop
off the head of any jew you can find
people of jerusalem we want you to cut
off the heads of the jews with knives
this is al-aqsa tv may 7. with your hand
cut their artery a knife costs
five shekels buy a knife put it here and
just cut off their heads
it costs just five shekels with those
five shekels you will humiliate the
jewish state
right literally just go around killing
jews don't worry guys there's moral
equivalents here
and the west has decided there's moral
equivalents here as far as the temple
mount hamas and the pa
used it as a military launching site we
have pictures
of them barricading the temple mount
they are bringing giant rocks into the
temple mount they brought fireworks into
the temple mount
they defaced the temple mount and
disgraced their own mosque by doing this
you can see them setting up these pipes
as a sort of barricade to prevent the
the israeli police from coming in and
stopping all of this nonsense
the riders were throwing rocks at cops
i can see them doing this here they are
this is on the temple mount
remember this is supposed to be a holy
site and they're using it literally
as a rioting site in order to attack
jews okay yesterday there was video
going around
of a tree that was on fire on the temple
mount ain't no jews
up there okay they've been barred it is
only palestinians and
and arabs who are up there right now
setting f
they set a fire to a tree there's a
video of jews down by the western wall
who are dancing
for jerusalem day and then the
palestinians take that video and they
say the jews are dancing over the
burning of the tree it's ridiculous
okay it is all propagandistic bull
nonsense it's just nonsense okay so how
do democrats respond
okay so here's how the democrats have
responded the biden administration put
out a statement
they condemned the rocket attacks and
they called for de-escalation because
this is
always the way instead of doing what the
trump administration did and did exactly
right
and say israel has a right to defend
itself period instead of saying israel
has a right
to control israeli sites and prevent
rioting and prevent disorder
and prevent people from attempting to
murder other people instead of saying
that
they suggested that israel has to calm
the region
it's always de-escalation de-escalation
who's escalating here
there's only one group of people who
decided to go up on the temple mount
which again is open daily all the time
to arabs
there's only one group of people who
decided to barricade it and fling rocks
at the cops
there's only one group of people who
decided to fire rockets randomly into
major
israeli cities okay the biden
administration puts out this mealy mouth
statement
the u.n has now suggested oh you know
it's kind of bad that they're firing
rockets but then they're always calling
for calm
oh we need calm you know how you
establish calm the way that you
establish calm is by not firing rockets
into civilian areas
and then you have the actual open
anti-semites of the squad so vilhain
omar
who is just a jew hater par excellence i
mean she just
doesn't like the jews she tweeted out
israeli airstrikes killing civilians in
gaza is an act of terrorism
israeli airstrikes are targeted at
islamic jihad and hamas members
and what would you call it when you have
rockets being randomly fired into
israeli cities
for no reason other than peak
palestinians deserve protection says
ilhan omar
unlike israel missile defense programs
such as iron dome don't exist to protect
palestinian civilians
it's true the palestinians have their
own iron dome it's called don't fire
rockets at israel
israel does not randomly fire rockets
into major
gaza centers of population that's just a
lie
every israeli military response has been
just that a military response
it is unconscionable to not condemn
these attacks on the week of aid because
of the the end of ramadan the holy week
of aid
you know what's irresponsible honor not
condemning
people on the temple mount to facing the
temple mount for purposes of terrorism
okay and then she tweeted out a video in
which the red crescent was this is a
propaganda video says
uh 163 palestinians have been injured 23
hospitalized as israelis fire sound
bombs and tear gas inside the al-aqsa
mosque compound now weird
because um the israelis have technically
control over the entire compound
so why isn't this every day if they just
wanted to clear it out why not every day
and the answer is because a bunch of
people showed up with fireworks and
rocks and started trying to murder
israeli soldiers
that's why so ilhan omar again jew hater
power excellent she tweeted out this is
happening as muslims pray
taraweeh and tahajud in palestine
families who pray all night during
ramadan the mosque is like home
palestinians deserve to find refuge in a
mosque in peace in ramadan
where is the media coverage speak up
against israeli occupation
terror okay now again i showed you the
pictures
i showed you the videos they literally
brought stockpiles of stones
to throw at israeli soldiers into the
mosque who defaced the mosque
who did it might it be the terrorist
groups who were flying
literally the hamas flag from the top of
the al-aqsa mosque
okay to come up with an equivalent you
would have to suggest that the
equivalent here
is let's say that there's a um a mosque
in the in the center of washington dc
directly across from the white house
and people at the mosque just decided to
bring al-qaeda flags and fly them
on top of the mosque hamas is a
terrorist group that stands openly for
the extermination of israel and the
destruction of every jew in the region
they flew that flag on israeli territory
inside the al-aqsa mosque
while gathering rocks to threat israeli
soldiers no hanoi's like look at those
terrible israelis look at those terrible
jews then you ever shoot it to lead who
also hates the jews
she tweeted out yesterday about it's so
terrible i mean the what's happening at
the eloqua mosque is just terrible
imagine if somebody did this to the
temple mount
they are doing it to the temple mount
the temple mount is the holiest
site in judaism it is currently being
used as a staging point a rallying point
for terrorism
here's rashida talib who again don't
like those jews very much
on msnbc condemning israel this is an
apartheid system i mean i mean
israel's own prominent human rights
organization bet salem
has declared it human rights watch has
declared it there is no
form of acceptance resistance to state
violence
except the denial of except for the
denial
of you know people's human dignity and
we need to stop we need to stop and look
at the fact that our own country is
enabling it
with billions of dollars every year
being issued
to israel even though they are promoting
racism and dehumanization
promoting racism and dehumanization the
arab party in israel is about to
determine who the prime minister
is how many they've taken polls by the
way of israeli arabs how many of them
would like to live
in nascent palestine the ants are pretty
much zero none
okay the reality is the palestinian
authority runs the palestinian areas
the gaza strip is run by hamas a
terrorist group the only apartheid state
in the region
is the state that actively will not
allow jews to live there and will murder
a jew if you accidentally drive into the
area
okay there are literally signs on
israeli highways that have
on the sign two arrows one that is green
stay on the highway
and one that is read and it will say in
hebrew on the signs the israeli
government cannot protect you if you go
into these areas you go so you do so at
risk to your life
you know what happens if a palestinian
accidentally wanders into israel
they get a cup of coffee and they go
back home that's what happens if they
accidentally
get in if they take the wrong turn off
the highway
there are checkpoints specifically
because there are people who keep
entering and attempting to commit acts
of terrorism if that stops so do the
checkpoints
members of the israeli government are
attempting to foster economic ties with
the palestinian areas
but it's very difficult when you have
the palestinian authority that is
actively fomenting terrorism
all of this is part and parcel of a
broader biden administration strategy
and you have the squad which is just
openly far left anti-semitic so some of
them are just open anti-semites like
gelhan omar and rashida talib then you
have just ignorant
ignoramuses and morons like aoc again
iq barely reaching into triple digits
perhaps
she tweets out we stand in solidarity
with the palestinian residents of sheikh
zarah in east jerusalem israeli forces
are forcing families from their homes
during ramadan and inflicting violence
it's inhumane the us must show
leadership in safeguarding the human
rights of palestinians again this is a
private legal dispute
and this is what she chooses to tweet
while people are engaging in actual
acts of rioting and violence and massive
rocket attacks
there's genius stuff there from the
squad again this is because the far left
has decided that they
do not like israel and the reason they
do not like israel is for the same
reason
that frankly they don't like america
very much and that is
in their view all of the world is a
zero-sum game if there is any group that
is successful in any group that is
unsuccessful it must be that the
successful group did something bad to
the unsuccessful group so if you can
create a coalition of the dispossessed
they can all get together and march
together to tear down the systems
that is the reason why you will see
black lives matter having statements
about palestine
in their in their bizarre little
manifesto
you're like what does this have to do
with anything the answer is that it's
all about creating this coalition of the
supposedly dispossessed to wreck the
system
that's really why the left sides with
all of this nonsense and meanwhile the
biden administration has its own plans
with regard to middle eastern
politics and that has to do with a broad
rejiggering
of how they hope middle eastern politics
goes and it's really done along obama
lines and what this really means is that
one of the fomenting factors here
is not just that the biden
administration decided to resign checks
to hamas
and the palestinian authority they also
decided they were going to
make nice with iran which is the great
terror sponsor in the middle east
because what they would like to see is
iran become a regional power supposedly
so the united states could like back off
so they think
okay we'll create a balance of power
between israel and iran which is
unbelievable we're actually fostering a
terror state
in extremis we are they're in a bad
situation iran and we are fostering that
terrorist state
because joe biden would love nothing
better than to restore some level of
balance of power in the middle east
by effectuating the power of a state
that openly changed death to america and
death to israel
it's pretty impressive stuff and by the
way becoming the propaganda arm we'll
get to that in
just one minute it's amazing how in just
three months
we can have a president who takes office
on the way
seriously he took office as the luckiest
man maybe ever to take american office
number one he didn't run a campaign
number two he took office in the wake of
a very unpopular president number three
he took office
in the middle of a naturally occurring
economic recovery for which he was not
responsible he took office in the middle
of a coveted pandemic for which the
vaccine had already been developed and a
vaccine
tranching plan had already been
developed he took office
the year after massive racial
conflagration in the united states and
he took office
with basically peace in the middle east
breaking out everywhere he's proceeded
to exacerbate the racial conflict in the
united states
destroy the economic growth curve
through his ridiculous spending programs
and set the middle east on fire by
incentivizing all the worst forces in
the middle east
and attempting to reverse the effect of
peace deals that were breaking out all
over the middle east
we're only four months in gang wait for
a few years okay in just a second
we'll get to joe biden and his plans for
the middle east first
let us talk about the fact that our eyes
were not meant to look at screens all
day it messes with your internal balance
that can affect your sleep
cause stress headaches blurry vision eye
fatigue felix gray glasses they filter
15 times more blue light from screens
than other clear
blue light lenses the original optical
lenses relieve most eye strain symptoms
from daily screen time
the more advanced sleep glasses relieve
serious daily eye strain and were
especially designed for late night
screen time
to improve sleep felix great frames they
are hand finished from italian acetate
making them durable
lightweight and super comfortable blue
light lenses come standard starting at
95 bucks
or add your prescription and check out
starting at 145 bucks if you don't love
those glasses
in the first 30 days their in-house
customer care team will take care of
exchanges and returns
no hassle no questions asked my felix
squared glasses they help me sleep
better at night because the fact is i'm
constantly on screens
all the time well if i don't want that
blue light keeping me awake i pop on the
felix gray glasses before bed and it
really helps even if i have to look at
screens felix's great glasses are
designed for the 21st century head on
over to felix grayglasses.com
bennett see shop glasses that work as
hard as you do that is
f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y-glasses.com
shipping free exchanges 30-day
money-back guarantee
felixgrayglasses.comgo
check them out right now okay we'll get
to more on this in just one second first
if you own an apple device
got good news for you all of the daily
wires latest news commentary analysis
now available for your reading pleasure
on apple news we cover everything you're
not getting anywhere else so
if you want to make your news feed
infinitely better just head on over to
apple news on your device
search for the daily wire hit the follow
button right now
also go subscribe over at dailywire.com
subscribe and help us out because there
are forces out there in the world that
don't want you to get truth they don't
want you get information
that bucks the narrative we need your
help head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe to join us today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so the fact is the biden administration
has this bizarre notion that they are
going to establish some sort of
balance of power a real politics
situation in the middle east
this started under barack obama who was
fully invested in the notion that iran
was going to provide a counterbalance to
the sunni arab states and that this
would somehow
make the region better which is insane
since the ayatollahs run iran this is
one of the reasons why
obama went super soft when the when the
iranian revolution was happening in 2009
he sort of looked the other way as
iranians got shot down
in the street there's a great piece over
a tablet
right now about the realignment in the
middle east that biden is attempting to
effectuate
and basically what they're attempting to
do is allow tehran to gain an economic
prominence they would
they would like to allow iran to get a
nuclear bomb by 2031.
they want to end the sanctions they want
to implement a policy of accommodation
of iran and its tentacles in iraq syria
yemen and lebanon and they want to force
that policy on america's closest
allies so they can establish this
so-called balance of power that is the
goal here
right this of course is going to be a
giant fail because every time you make
concessions to iran iran immediately
gets more militant right this is what
they do so right now
just this the last few weeks there have
been these ongoing bullcrap negotiations
in europe between
biden and the iranian leaders and
they're not in the same room together
they're staying in two separate hotel
rooms and they have couriers who are
running back and forth with letters
and it turns out that iran doesn't want
to dismantle any of its new nuclear
activities since the advent of the trump
administration and the end of the
original iran deal
the biden administration is looking at
them and going well we need something we
need some sort of fig leaf
so that we can remove the economic
sanctions at this point
but it is clear that the white house
wants to make accommodations for the
iranian government despite the fact that
we don't need to make accommodations for
the iranian government
we've already made a bunch of
accommodations for the iranian
government for example
the biden administration on entering
office immediately oriented itself
anti-saudi
right the trump administration was quite
pro saudi because saudi was pushing very
hard for peace deals in the middle east
to to create a sort of anti-iranian
alliance ironically caused by
by barack obama's support for iran the
biden administration came in attempted
to reverse all that their first move was
to declare that the houthis in yemen
were not actually a terrorist entity
which of course is insane the houthis
are in fact a terrorist entity
then they decided that they were going
to release that report on jamal
khashoggi
and the murder of jamal khashoggi at the
hands of the saudi monarchy
that was like a two-year-old story they
decided to release the report to
generate some cover
for the fact that they were now siding
pretty openly with iran
iran's meanwhile they were trying to
press forward this negotiation with iran
in order to pay iran in order to try and
strengthen iran
and their hope was that iran would then
somehow moderate become wonderful be a
counter-balance to the saudi regime
the iranians in these negotiations have
been demanding according to the new york
times that they'd be allowed to keep the
advanced nuclear fuel production
equipment they installed after trump
abandoned the pact
and integration with the world financial
system beyond what they achieved under
the 2015 agreement
the biden administration says restoring
the old deal is just a stepping stone
right okay so this is the great lie what
they're going to say is we are
our this is the first deal we sign which
is just a bunch of concessions to iran
that's just a stepping stone but here's
the thing
it isn't just a stepping stone because
usually a stepping stone is followed by
another stone
if it's just a stone in the middle of
the water you're just standing there in
the middle of a river and that's what
the biden administration
is doing right now with regard to iran
iran for its part
is trying to pressure the biden
administration and intimidate the biden
administration by getting violent
this is their goal so yesterday for
example the u.s coast guard cutter maui
had to fire 30 warning shots from a 50
caliber machine gun this is yesterday
after a group of 13 iranian
revolutionary guard
navy fastboats conducted unsafe and
unprofessional maneuvers while operating
close to a u.s naval formation in the
strait of hormuz so basically he had 13
irgc navy boats these tiny little boats
were harassing a u.s
coast guard boat you'll remember that
during the obama administration they
actually
captured some american soldiers and
there were those humiliating photos of
american soldiers on their knees
as the iranian revolutionary guards
stood around them and then
iran let it go but not before building a
giant statue of this directly in the
middle of tehran which they actually did
so here's the best part the biden
administration is so invested
in the lie that iran is moderate they're
so invested in the lie that they can
somehow bring iran to the table which of
course
foments terrorism across the middle east
that a pentagon spokesperson yesterday
was asked about this incident
in which iranian ships were harassing
american ships and american ships
actually had to fire over their heads as
a warning shot
by saying this is the pentagon
spokesperson he said well you know maybe
iran doesn't control the navy
this is what we've been relegated to the
american administration is now
playing open propaganda for the iranian
regime
okay this is all wrong-headed it is
insane it's going to cause people to die
in the middle east it's that simple
here is the pentagon spokesperson
playing actual propagandists for the
iranian regime
i don't think at this point that we have
a great sense of the command and control
element here for the irgc navy
i think you know the irgc navy reports
directly to the supreme leader
uh but what level of command and control
and visibility there was
from tehran um i don't think we know
that right now okay they're just making
excuses can you imagine anything like
this like on the american side really
like any other country
where their navy is harassing our ships
and we're like well you know maybe the
government's just not in control of
their navy
it's their navy pretty sure they know
what they're doing but here's the thing
when you have fostered a lie that you
now have to live with you have to make
excuses for the lie
and this is the pattern in the in the
obama part three administration the
biden administration
the pattern is you have a lie the lie is
that iran is a moderating power that can
be moderated if we just make nice with
them
then that lie is proved by the fact that
they get extremely militant
in the in in the straits of hormuz
harassing american ships and so now you
have to promulgate the lies so well i
guess the iranians don't know what
they're doing
same thing in the middle east same thing
with regards to the palestinians you
have to promulgate the lie that there's
a moral equivalence between hamas
and palestinian authority in islamic
jihad and the israelis and then it turns
out they're firing rockets
at israeli cities for no reason and so
now you have to say well you know it
must be just because of escalation of
de-escalation guys we just need
de-escalation this is true
throughout leftist thought as soon as
your ideology is debunked by real world
events
you have to start making excuses for why
that's not true and inevitably that
means you are defending some of the
worst people on earth this happens
over and over and over again because if
you are so invested
in your idea of what's true that the
actual truth doesn't matter
that means you have to lie by necessity
and this is what the bible
administration is doing on foreign
policy
right now meanwhile in another show of
unbelievable weakness we are now
experiencing
jimmy carter-esque gas lines the reason
for this is not because of actual
gasoline shortages at this point it's
because of this ransomware attack
on a major u.s pipeline it is the work
of a criminal gang called
darkseid according to the fbi the cyber
extortion attempt according to cbs news
that's forced the shutdown of a vital us
pipeline was carried out by a criminal
gang known as darkseid that cultivates a
robin hood image of stealing from
corporations
and giving a cut to charity the fbi said
on monday the shutdown stretched into
its third
full day with the biden administration
loosening regulations of the transport
of petroleum products on highways
as part of an all hands on deck effort
to avoid disruptions in the fuel supply
georgia-based colonial pipeline said
monday it hopes to have service mostly
restored by the end
of the week the pipeline carries
gasoline and other fuel from texas to
the northeast
it delivers roughly 45 percent of fuel
consumed on the east coast according to
the company
it was hit by what colonial called a
ransomware attack in which hackers
typically lock up computer systems by
encrypting data and paralyzing networks
then demand a large ransom to unscramble
it
so hilariously the white house was asked
about all of this
and the white house's response to you
know what looks like an actual foreign
attack on american domestic
infrastructure
it looks as though their response was
well it's a private problem
which is unbelievable you want to talk
about a weak it seems like kind of
an american foreign policy problem when
you shut down 45 of the gas supply to
the southeast
but here is the white house press
secretary yesterday trying to explain
this away as it's a private decision
whether colonial decides to pay off the
russian hackers or not
so first we recognize that victims of
cyber attacks often face a very
difficult situation
and they have to just balance often the
cost benefit when they have no choice
with regard to paying a ransom
colonial is a private company and will
defer information regarding
their decision on paying a ransom to
them
what do you mean they're a private
company and and like
what excuse me so normally if somebody
kidnaps your child and ransoms them
that's a matter that involves the police
would it not now you'd want law
enforcement involved at this point but
here they're like well you know i guess
colonial
if they decide to pay a ransom that's
that's not colonial
meanwhile colonial said it is developing
a re a system restart plan
they said that their main pipeline
remains offline some smaller lines are
now
operational this administration is just
a bleep show
they're just a bleep show commerce
secretary gina raimondo said sunday
ransomware attacks are what businesses
now have to worry about
and she says she will work vigorously
with the department of homeland security
to address the problem
calling it a top priority for the
administration she says
we have to work in partnership with
business to secure networks to defend
ourselves against
these attacks she says it's an all hands
on deck effort right now we're working
closely with the company state and local
officials
okay you know what'd be great is if
somebody would tell the white house
that it's not merely a private question
as to whether colonial pays ransom here
unbelievable unbelievable
meanwhile gas stations are suffering
shortages all over
the southeastern united states the
closure of that 5 500
mile colonial pipeline which carries
more than 100 million gallons of fuel
from texas to new jersey each day
has stretched now into its fifth day
so it's great we're bringing back the
70s guys all the good stuff we got
inflation
we've got conflict in the middle east
we've gotten emboldened iran
we have gas lines like this is really
great especially coming off of a
pandemic
again joe biden was handed the most
salutory conditions for any president i
have ever seen entering office
and his immediate move is to blow it all
it's unbelievable how incompetent he is
or maybe its competence just directed in
the wrong direction
meanwhile the good news is the democrats
want to just imitate joe biden's actions
all across the way i mean it's amazing
so joe biden has somehow produced he
inherited
just to get this straight joe biden
inherited a
vaccine that works a vaccine
distribution plan an economy sets a boom
and peace in the middle east and in his
first three months he has produced deep
vaccine hesitancy a dramatically
underperforming economy
inflation gas shortages and a middle
eastern war really well done here
joe biden so naturally democrats are
like what if we did that so governor
gavin newsom
in california announced on monday his
state is projected to have
a 38 billion discretionary surplus in
2021.
now again that's largely because the
federal government has decided to send
checks to all of these states
he said he wants to use it to expand the
state's stimulus program he's going to
send checks to two-thirds of california
residents
california already has the highest
estimated debt of any state according to
breitbart with nearly 363 billion
dollars in liabilities
in 2019. but gavin newsom has a plan
his plan is he's going to send you a
check he's going to send you a check
and how's that this is certainly going
to help with unemployment in the golden
state paying people to stay home
it certainly it has nothing to do with
the fact that he's being recalled in the
state of california so here's the thing
the economic plans by the democrats here
they don't work but they do work in one
sense people like free money
and so long as you're telling people
they get free money it doesn't matter
because
inflation is the indirect result of a
lot of these policies so long as it's
indirect
you can claim that it's something else
that's causing the economic
supply line problems so that's what
gavin newsom is doing
democrats across the country are
pursuing these giant tax and spend
policies
these horrible policies on crime these
terrible
fiscal policies and then the people who
reap the
who reap the whirlwind are all of the
citizens of these states who then are
lied to by the media who insist that you
keep electing democrats in order to do
more of this stuff
recognize that the joe biden gavin
newsom i think will survive the recall
joe biden according to some estimates
has a 60
approval rating 60 now i don't believe
that for a second
but joe biden having a 60 approval
rating despite a dramatically
underperforming economy war in the
middle east inflation on the horizon
a dramatically polarized racial problem
in the united states
it just demonstrates that the kind of
heavy lifting the media will do on
behalf of democrats
are either unbelievably incompetent or
malevolent or both
the biden administration has been a junk
heap thus far
just terrible but we're all supposed to
pretend that he's doing a wonderful
wonderful job he's after all he's a
kindly old fellow
well we'll be back here later today with
an additional hour of the ben shapiro
show coming up soon the matt wall show
airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check
it out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show
you